la primera respuesta sanciones este
martes durante todo el día occidente ha
estado anunciando los primeros castigos
a rusia en la tarde del presidente de
eeuu joe biden anunció sanciones a lo
que ya considera el principio de una
invasión entre estas medidas está cortar
las vías de financiación de la deuda
soberana y que rusia no pueda obtener
dinero de occidente además sancionar a
élites rusas y sus familiares promete el
bloqueo de operaciones en el banco de
desarrollo ruso y del banco militar y
aumentará la presencia militar en el mar
báltico
mientras rusia prepara su próximo
movimiento nosotros preparamos los
nuestros rusia pagará un precio aún más
alto si continúa con esta agresión
incluyendo sanciones adicionales los
eeuu continuarán dando asistencia
defensiva a ucrania con sus aliados de
la otan
antes había sido la unión europea la que
había respondido con sanciones dirigidas
a los 351 legisladores de la duma que
votaron a favor del reconocimiento de
independencia y 27 funcionarios e
instituciones rusas
de la defensa y la banca a los que se
les congelarán activos y se les
prohibirán visados también prohibirán a
inversores de la unión europea a
comerciar con bonos estatales y tampoco
podrán importar o exportar con las dos
regiones separatistas
estamos fuertemente unidos en este
frente y aumentaremos sustancialmente el
nivel de las sanciones de acuerdo con el
comportamiento de rusia acorde en
relación de javier destacada fue la
decisión de alemania que detuvo el
proyecto de gasoducto del mar báltico
north stream 2 diseñado para duplicar el
flujo de gas ruso directo a alemania
mientras reino unido sanciona cinco
bancos rusos y tres personas de la élite
y canadá anunció también castigos
económicos y el envío de más tropas a
letonia